edward snowdon est un ancien employé des
services de renseignement américains il
a aussi travaillé pour une compagnie qui
faisait affaire avec la msa
il est devenu célèbre en 2013 lorsqu'il
a levé le voile sur l'existence d'un
vaste système international de
surveillance de masse ces révélations
ont eu l'effet d'une bombe et edward
snowdon est devenu instantanément un des
hommes les plus recherchés du monde au
moment de l'éclatement de ce scandale et
dwight snowdon se trouvait en asie il
s'est caché chez des demandeurs d'asile
philippins et sri lankais pendant
quelques jours en compte ces gens qui
étaient des clients de l'avocat du
lanceur d'alert ont été surnommés les
anges gardiens de snowdon un rôle qui
leur a valu bien des tracas avec les
autorités de hong kong
edouard snowdon lui s'est par la suite
enfui en russie moscou a fini par lui
accorder l'asile et il habite dans un
endroit gardé secret mais il demeure
activement recherché par les états unis
il est notamment accusé d'avoir violé la
loi américaine sur l'espionnage